so how about as a kid like were you
entrepreneurial yeah so I grew up in
Missouri and then I went to college in
Tennessee and when I was in Tennessee I
own a chain of hot dogs science called
southern Sam's wieners as big as a
baby's arm man and like how old were you
I started when I was like 20 but before
that I was selling stuff on eBay but
like that was my first legal business I
got business license and paid taxes and
things like that have you seen a TV show
called American Pickers yes
so Mike the main guy the skinny guy I
met him on the street cuz I was a big
fan and I asked him to work at his
company at his store he was opened up a
store where they sell like all the old
[__] and I worked there and it was great
but there was always a line of like a
thousand people and I was like I'm gonna
go open up a hotdog stand some hotdogs
these people and that's what happened
because the show was so famous tapia
when I worked there in 2011 or no sorry
2008 or 9 or something like that we were
number two on cable behind Pawn Stars
and all these people from around the
world would come and get in this line
where was that it was in Nashville and
it but is he like he's into old stuff
right so he got this old building that
was away from everything and there's no
restaurants and I was like huh these
guys I'm from the south so I can say
this but they're kind of rednecks who
would come and wait in line and I was
like these [__] what's up hot dogs at
water that's all they want and I opened
up this hotdog stand and that was like
my first hustle yeah first business made
money and I'd pay taxes and got licenses
and how did that go how long did you do
it for a few years I mean you would make
a great a day on a good day
yeah it was awesome and then I started a
website that made a little bit of money
but I was like oh the Internet's the way
to go and so I left school and moved out
to Silicon Valley in San Francisco and
originally had job offers at Airbnb but
at the time was called air
bed-and-breakfast but I was like you
know screwed this let's try to start
something so I started a roommate
matching app that had a small exit and
then kind of parlayed that into the
hustle and what I'm doing now and what
was that company called and who did sell
- it was called bunk originally bunk SF
it was what we would do is
kind of funny we would cold email all
these landlords and apartments of who
had two three four five bedroom
apartments and then we would host
parties so people who had similar once
and needs for living situation could all
meet one another and we would help them
move into these buildings and we would
take a small cut of like a placement fee
and so it was a small exit like hundreds
of thousands of dollars to apartment
lists apartment list comm did you have
to work in that company or now yeah and
I quit on the first day yeah like that
last day how was that how would you know
as somebody who now it sounds like your
whole career has been for yourself how
was that year working say was good like
I still don't know [__] like I had to
read books on like how to run a meeting
so I felt like I moved to San Francisco
from Tennessee I and I'm gripping
Missouri I always felt really
uncomfortable not a place there but I
love it now I didn't know anything like
I would say things that were
inappropriate I would wear stuff I
wasn't supposed to wear I just felt
horrible so it was good to see like what
an actual business is run like but I was
also young I was 22 and I was partying
and I didn't take it as seriously as I
should have and I regret that big time
but it was great to see what was the
biggest table would you argue the one or
two or three biggest takeaways were from
that year even though you're like okay
so you guys have a great setup here okay
um you started in like a small room I
imagine that's a shitty office that's
right and so just seeing like wait I
could take all these little silly things
like a hotdog stand or whatever and like
properly build it out with nice offices
after you get revenue and like like I
need you in order to get huge as big as
my ambitions where you really need to
properly approach things and be able to
like have a proper levels as opposed to
have you started the challenge proper so
like for example what was funny running
through my mind and when you just said
you know I read books on how to run a
meeting properly I was like laughing in
my head because I was like [__] man I
probably hate that book right because
like to me like meetings and like how
the world those proper things you're
referring to see meetings and how I
personally see meetings there's a huge
Delta and I'm Kaldur you now I just I'm
30 I'm curious you know
someone who also came from Adam
and never understood proper I always
wonder I'm always challenging myself of
like what was I naturally gifted in in
an entrepreneurial and human way what
has evolved over these 22 years of
operating and what have I taken on that
is horseshit
because it's osmosis yeah I know I feel
you but here in my mind it's like this
okay when you play an instrument when
you learn a guitar you don't it's most
people don't play songs of their own
songs right away they kind of copy other
people and feel the texture and they go
oh I see some kind of like the stuff
that I like I see a recurring patterns
yep this is interesting I can I can
disregard this other stuff so what I do
is I usually read books
I'll read like I'll read your guyses
glass doors okay
other companies glass doors about what
people say well yeah like what's the
baseline for like what is interesting
and I can you can hit cherry-pick but
you don't know like anything you have
it's easier to have like a model and
then you can know what to disregard yeah
but I would argue that your analogy for
the way you went about it unless I'm
missing something is actually not flawed
but not exactly the same analogy because
it sounds like based on your hot dog
business what you're telling me is you
didn't play other people's music you
picked it up started playing something
and within that micro area it worked
I would also I would also argue that you
know it's really interesting where the
source of information comes from right
so there's a lot of business books being
written by people who've never run a
bibliography
fair enough Glassdoor is just anonymous
reviews yeah very dirty do one foreign
or one other end that's what I mean I
mean you're at this young age where
you've had these levels of successes you
know I have such empathy for where
you're coming from because I'm sure I
had a lot of those same feelings of like
I'm from out of bounds I don't go to
business school and things of that
nature and I remember ironically it's an
interesting for you to bring that up
I also remember kind of hitting the
Silicon Valley scene and like every
single person went to Stanford and
Harvard it's uncomfortable and I was
like thank God for me very different for
you that I already had such a real
significant win that I was able to kind
of use that but I have so much empathy
for what must have been going through
your mind in that scenario on the flips
you're catching me at a very funny time
where I would not what are we 20 for
these eight weeks are probably the
favorite eight weeks of being an
operator in a long time because I
decided going into this year that I was
gonna go more me because I really let
the company do its thing I'm running the
company but I've let the osmosis of like
classic executives have a lot of say
over the last half decade and I would
argue that the last eight weeks have
been some of those productive weeks at
vaynermedia's history and definitely my
favorite time in the last 40 years
because I'm going back a little bit to
hotdogs with the baby arm [__] yeah I I
don't disagree we agree I think that but
it's still important it was important
for me to understand because you needed
that contact yeah I get it I get it like
problems like my thing all right I'm
just gonna pick take this thousand
dollars in cash I'm gonna put that [__]
right in my pocket right like but you
don't you know spend it on some dumb
[__] oh you got it keep going
you know I just did do things right
didn't do more accounting things like
that now that we have an eight figure
you know we make seven figures a month
is it good I think it can be a very
large company just learning how to do
[__] properly now not everything needs
to be proper know the outside world but
like there are some things like I got to
make sure I do things the right way 100%
you know when things go from just have
you brought in people like I said Adam
is our president which who I knew from
high school he kind of he's the
president runs a lot of the day-to-day
stuff he's a straight man yeah yeah and
so I'm able to like I'm able to kind of
be my while itself and then well we
don't always meet in the middle
sometimes I will still go the wild route
but like there I have some proper
procedures dude for a while I was doing
the accounting and not good a night it
was like I thought cash flow and revenue
were the same thing like guys we got to
get these people put that money in our
bank that's not revenue I'm not paying
your quota on that and I get it and then
you can learn all that right stuff you
know how that the right way to do it
that's what I'm referring to I totally
understand you know how it is like not
coming from this area it's really
uncomfortable at first but it's actually
a advantage in the end I think a hundred
thousand percent I used to have this
book club called the anti MBA because
when I moved to San Francisco
so jealous of all these Stanford people
so I would create this book club and
we'd meet once a week and then we'd get
experts to come in and lead the
discussion and I was like we just did
the same thing as Stanford of course but
yeah it's really uncomfortable I think
and you know how it is
[Music]